thank you for joining us America this is
a free call and we're glad you're here
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five two two five coltan is in
Phoenix Arizona hi Colton how are you
kid are you Dave better than I deserve
what's up
alright well quick question I'm 18 years
old I graduated high school about a
month ago
I'm totally debt free I have a fully
fund emergency fund the company I'm
working for I'm sorry is a pain for my
college fully so I was just wondering
what my next steps in the process are do
I say for a how so I started saving for
retirement or just what the next steps
are what are you studying in college I'm
actually majoring in finance okay and
what kind of a track are you on it the
way you're going how long it take you to
graduate um well actually I'm about a
semester ahead than my graduating class
I should be out in probably three to
three and a half years who's paying for
this which company FedEx very cool and
so you're working FedEx what in shipping
or something yeah I'm a package handler
at the airport so unload planes load
plane and they have a tuition plan at
FedEx that pays a hundred percent of
your school yeah well they pay up to a
certain amount and that mount is about
what I pay per year so it all works out
yeah it does work out I want to know
more about this yes I'm about to endorse
FedEx to get rid of our student loan
problem in America so you're studying
finance where it what's college well I'm
going Community College right now and
that's why it's a lot cheaper than going
to university per se but so let me get
this straight
you're 18 years old you're working
delete you're working throwing packages
how many hours a week um I put in
probably around 40 yeah and then you're
going to school at Community College and
your own track your ahead to get your
finance degree early yes yes they're
your stud thank you I appreciate it your
your your your give me hope for America
we may make it long as there's young men
like you and when I go FedEx way to go
fat
just completely stinking so somebody
from FedEx get in touch with James
child's I'm about to give you people
some free PR if you'll tell us the
details on how this program works
because UPS has a program similar at
Louisville at their home office and if
you work in Louisville up there 20 hours
plus they'll pay for your college at one
of three different colleges there in the
area or they used to I think it's still
there and so you know everybody wants to
know how you can get a college nasty
noon well you need to meet Colton is how
you go to college our student loan he's
got a brain in this head way to go dude
way to go so here's what I want you to
do I think one of the best investments
Colton could make is in Colton because I
think the return on investment on Colton
is going to be phenomenal you've got
such a great start here you've obviously
got the intellect and the work ethic and
the street cred to do everything you're
wanting to do so keep with what you're
doing but just in case there's a hiccup
I want there to be a pile of money to
call to ensure that Colton finishes
school debt-free and all the time so I
my investment if I'm you is I want you
to pile up money as high as you can pile
it until you graduate I don't want you
doing any long-term investing right now
and the reason for that is very simple I
want you to make sure you pay for school
all the way through now when you
graduate from college if you're sitting
on 40 or 50 thousand dollars you can do
whatever you want to do right right and
you'll be in no debt at all what a way
to start hello and then you take that
quote grown-up job unquote and with the
finance degree and you maybe buy a house
and you maybe get married you maybe got
a lot of money to do all of those things
that's going to give you a kickstart and
whatever investing hours or investing
compound interest you've lost over this
next couple of years you'll regain it
very quickly by having been street smart
you follow it all right yeah that's how
great so just don't touch it it's not to
buy a freaking bass boat or go to Cancun
all right now this is piling up money so
you finish your education on time
without any debt and you don't and you
know Fed Ex doesn't have a hiccup and
bust you out into the street somehow and
yet this thing not work I want this plan
to be finished I want to hear
the end of the story alrighty I
appreciate it so that's how I would do
it way to go dude man that's awesome is
that does that does that set me up for a
student loan rent right there I could go
for about 45 minutes right now on how
stupid student loans are after talking
to that young stud Wow that could set me
up for that I'm not going to do it
though maybe I am but no I'm not okay
Oh